hey 42 here
on the 13th of April 1970 three
astronauts were broadcasting back to
Earth beaming a rare live look inside a
spaceship and one of the most important
missions in history
Jim Lovell Jack swiggett and Fred Hayes
were heading for the moon where they've
all went to plan Lovell and Hayes had
become the fifth and sixth humans to
walk on its surface all three men were
in High Spirits chuckling and chortling
for the camera even playing practical
jokes on one another
back on Earth at Mission Control in
Houston Texas the mood was equally
buoyant the first 55 hours had gone so
smoothly that capsule Communicator Joe
Kerwin cops that he and the rest of the
team were bored to tears in hindsight
tempting fate with practical jokes and
talk of boredom was a bad idea because
if there's one place you don't want to
DARE the universe to make an example of
you it's at a tiny spaceship two hundred
thousand miles from home
Louisville closed the broadcast by
wishing the people of Earth a pleasant
evening sporting a beaming grin on his
face
good night
however it didn't stay there for long
okay
because shortly after Jim Lovell Jack
swigert and Fred Hayes were fighting for
their lives in a crippled spaceship that
seemed certain to become their cold
cramped coffin
the question on there and everyone
else's lips was simple would they make
it home alive this is the remarkable
story of the most magnificent mishap in
the history of space flight
[Applause]
this is Apollo 30.
let me ask do you ever feel like
everyone else is getting better deals
than you then you need to start using
honey is the number one shopping tool in
America with over one hundred thousand
five-star Google reviews it
automatically searches for promo codes
on lots of your favorite websites so you
don't have to just imagine shopping
online and having your very own savings
sidekick finding you discounts of 18 on
average well that's honey it's just a
little button at the top of your browser
that's always ready to help you save
money so how's it work well it's super
simple first you need to add the honey
extension to your browser then you just
shop online like you usually would when
you reach the checkout page honey will
automatically pop up and search for any
available promo codes and automatically
apply the best saving possible to your
basket and the best part is honey works
for things you're already buying on lots
of sites you're already shopping on so
it's not like you have to change
anything you'll just end up spending
less so what are you waiting for add
honey to your browser for free at
joinhoney.com
42 make sure you use that link
joinhoney.com42 to support this Channel
and a big thanks to honey for sponsoring
this video
it's easy to assume that the eyes of the
world are on the crew of Apollo first
scene as they blasted off from the
Kennedy Space Center in Florida but the
truth is most people didn't even know
the launch was happening Apollo 13 was
to be their fifth manned mission to the
moon and its astronauts would be the
third crew to step foot on its surface
what would be huge news today was old
news Back in 1970
as a result that broadcast I just
mentioned the one that should have given
the public an incredible insight into
the life of a space shuttle heading to
the Moon yeah not a single station
picked it up and it was never actually
shown on TV
if it had been those who watched would
have witnessed the Stillness before
space Explorations most severe storm
because within six and a half minutes of
the Apollo 13 crew waving goodbye to an
absent audience a large chunk of their
spacecraft EX exploded
a loud bang bellowed and scores of
warning light simultaneously blinked on
it was Jack swigert who first reported
the bad news to Mission Control in what
is now one of the most famous quotes in
history Houston we have a problem
except that isn't actually what he said
Apple Proclamation was the pronouncedly
less pithy okay Houston we've had a
problem here the misquote was made
famous by the 1995 film Apollo first
scene but it wasn't so much a mistake as
a deliberate rewriting of History the
modified line particularly the change
from past to present tense was deemed
more dramatic anyway the exact wording
Doesn't Matter What mattered was that
the crew of Apollo 13 were now
officially fought
so many of the spaceship systems went
South so swiftly that the guys in
Mission Control assumed their
instruments were playing up Jim Lovell
had another theory he thought they'd
been hit by a meteor as it happens they
were both wrong a faulty wire had caused
an explosion that destroyed the ship's
vital oxygen tanks
short of the insta death of a
decompression incident it was just about
the worst possible thing that could
happen it wasn't just that the crew
needed oxygen for you know not dying the
ship did too the Apollo 13 Command
Module which housed a cruise
accommodation and many of the ship's
critical systems was powered by free
electrochemical fuel cells and the cells
themselves were fed by a combination of
hydrogen and oxygen no oxygen meant no
electricity and no electricity meant
almost nothing in the entire Command
Module would work
before the explosion the Apollo 13 crew
had been speeding towards the moon and a
place in history
after it they were scrambling simply to
survive the first and most pressing
obstacle to overcome was the minor
concern that the oxygen was about to run
out
the Apollo 13 spacecraft was split into
three parts The Command Module the
service module and the lunar module
without power The Command Module was
essentially dead and the service module
which housed the recently exploded
oxygen tanks and other consumables
contained no living space
that left the lunar module the craft
that would have taken level and Haze
down to the surface of the Moon had the
mission not gone to Absolute shite
the lunar lander was a tight fit for
free grown men and it hadn't been
designed for prolonged occupation it
didn't even have seats and in places its
outer shell was less than a millimeter
thick that was the bad news but the good
news was life-saving the lunar module
was essentially a self-contained unit it
had its own life support system and was
powered by dedicated batteries with
oxygen and therefore power rapidly
depleting in the Command Module the
astronauts made a Mad Dash for the lunar
module swiggit stayed behind to shut
down the sundry electrical systems to
save what little power was left they
were going to need it if they ever made
it back to Earth whilst Lovell got to
work transferring vital navigational
data from the computer in the Command
Module to the one in the lunar module
unfortunately for level the computers
use different coordinate systems so he
was forced to do some on-the-fly algebra
to convert between the two considering
any errors would likely have meant death
for him and his friends it was a bit
like doing an undergraduate mathematics
exam whilst the universe held a gun to
his Temple
luckily Lovell was an absolute badass
and he passed her flying colors
for the next three and a half days the
lunar module will become the astronaut's
Lifeboat in the sea of space a tiny
Oasis in the deadliest desert in the
universe but whilst the immediate oh
we're all about to die danger had
passed there was still a small matter of
how the hell they were going to get home
remember at this point they were still
speeding away from Earth towards the
moon the most obvious course of action
was to fire the main Thruster to turn
the ship around it was the fastest way
to get home but it was also risky it
would mean draining most of the
remaining power from the command
module's fuel cells and even worse the
froster was located on the recently
exploded service module neither the crew
nor Mission Control had any way of
knowing whether it had been damaged in
the blast in a worst case scenario
firing it could have blown the entire
ship into a million pieces
that was far from ideal so NASA's best
and brightest came up with a radical
Plan B
you see the service module wasn't the
only part of the ship equipped with a
froster the lunar module had one too
designed to control the Landers descends
down to the surface of the Moon it was
significantly less powerful than the
main froster so an immediate yui wasn't
possible but it did have enough power to
nudge the ship's course just enough to
put it on an earth re-entry trajectory
after slingshoting around the Moon it
would be much slower than an immediate
abort using the main Thruster but it was
also significantly safer the decision
ultimately lay with flight director Jean
Kranz and after careful consideration he
plays his bet on the tortoise rather
than the hair as Apollo 13 swung Around
The Far Side of the Moon the crew
performed a 34 second burn of the lunar
module's descent propulsion system to
put the craft back on a re-entry
trajectory followed by a second longer
burn to speed up the journey home by
about 12 hours that last part was
crucial because time was most certainly
of the essence
Plan B may have avoided the possible
game over screen of firing the
potentially damaged main Thruster but it
came with grave dangers of its own the
lunar module was designed to accommodate
two astronauts on the surface of the
Moon for about two days but after its
entirely unexpected career change from
lunalanda to long-term Lifeboat it was
going to have to support three
astronauts for three and a half days you
don't have to be Pythagoras to see that
those sums don't add up and every single
consumable resource energy food water
and oxygen would have to be stretched to
the absolute limit if the crew were to
stand any chance of returning to Terra
Firma the lunar module had its own
batteries but they'd never been intended
for such prolonged use if they died so
too would the crew so all non-essential
systems were shut down reducing energy
consumption to about one-fifth of its
typical rate
problem was the ship's electrical
systems also happened to be an important
source of passive heat with most of them
powered down the temperature inside the
ship plummeted to just three degrees
Celsius about what you'd find in a
fridge
for the most part food wasn't an issue
the crew still had access to the
crippled Command Module where there was
plenty of grub floating around literally
although some of it had froze water
however was a different story there was
a small potable reserve on board but
most of the water was supposed to be
made along the way as a byproduct of
reactions in the ship's fuel cells you
know the broken ones and many of the
ship's critical systems relied on water
cooling so in an effort to make sure
there was enough of the wet stuff for
both man and machine the astronauts were
put on a water ration of just 200
milliliters per person per day
surprisingly oxygen wasn't actually a
concern despite being designed for a
two-day stay on the moon the lunar
module had contingency built in which
included a large quantity of excess
oxygen unfortunately the crew also had
an excess of something much less
desirable about a day and a half after
relocating into the lunar module yet
another warning Glide started to Blink
the carbon dioxide level was getting
dangerously High the lunar module was
equipped with a CO2 filtration system
but like everything else it hadn't been
designed for such prolonged and
intensive use
the system relied on canisters of CO2
scrubbing lithium hydroxide pellets but
they could only absorb so much before
becoming saturated
luckily there were plenty of spare
canisters in the Command Module
unfucking luckily they were Square
shaped and incompatible with the round
filter housing in the lunar module in
hindsight that was a huge oversight
there was no reason whatsoever for the
canisters to be incompatible across the
two modules but it was far too late for
finger pointing if they didn't find a
solution fast level swigert and Haze
were dead men walking
it was a life or death situation but it
was also kind of hard not to appreciate
the irony of NASA being forced to focus
to combine brain power of its most
brilliant Engineers on the age-old
problem of trying to fit a square peg
into a round hole the solution they came
up with was suitably ingenious limited
only by what would be available to the
astronauts they hashed out a design for
a filter adapter using a spacesuit hose
several plastic sample bags cardboard
torn from logbook covers and a rolled up
suck
this ridiculous Contraption was held
together with duct tape and looked about
as sophisticated as a crackhead in drag
but as soon as the astronauts finished
putting it together the CO2 levels began
to drop
despite having once again successfully
managed to not die things were going
from bad to worse the crew were
forbidden from venting urine out into
space for fear the tiny Jets of we would
Propel the craft of course and after
several days peeing in plastic bags
there were pouches of piss all over the
place in summary love all swigert and
Haze were cold they were dehydrated and
they were perpetually assaulted by
plastic pockets of their own piss but if
Lovell and his crew fought their luck
was about to change they were mistaken
because as Earth grew ever larger
outside the spacecraft's windows Mission
Control got in touch with yet more bad
news they drifted off course instead of
penetrating girth's atmosphere as
intended they were going to bounce off
it like a skimming Stone if that
happened there would be no Second
Chances the spaceship would become their
two manned their Frozen corpses would
remain in a loose orbit around Earth for
thousands perhaps millions of years
now I know what you're thinking they'd
already corrected their Course once why
not just do it again
unfortunately it wasn't that easy the
previous course correction had leveraged
the moon's gravity in tandem with the
thrusters this time so close to Earth
and without the moon's gravity to help
out
they were going to have to take matters
into their own hands
literally
with the guidance computer powered down
the ship's location and orientation was
uncertain they grabbed hold of the
controls and using the Sun as a
reference point manually lined the ship
up for re-entry this was entirely
Uncharted Territory no crew had ever
attempted anything like it before get it
wrong and they would be dead get it
right and well they still might be dead
but at least they'd have a chance
five hours before scheduled re-entry
into Earth's atmosphere Mission Control
gave them the go-ahead to execute the
burn
under unimaginable pressure level
swigert and Haze pulled off this
unprecedented maneuver perfectly so
perfectly in fact that by the time they
shut off the thrusters they were within
half a degree of their intended angle of
approach Apollo 13 was coming home
the lunar module had served the
astronauts remarkably well over the past
three and a half days but the time had
come to leave it behind because only one
part of the Apollo spacecraft was
capable of withstanding the enormous
temperatures of re-entry The Command
Module
there was of course one slight problem
with that the crippled Command Module
had been powered down three and a half
days earlier Engineers on the ground had
spent the intervening time trying to
figure out how the hell they were going
to bring it back online again using only
the lunar module's Mega Battery nobody
had ever powered down a Command Module
in space before and the team had to ride
an entirely new procedure from scratch
it ran to over 500 individual steps and
it was down to the absolutely bloody
knackered dangerously dehydrated Jack
swigert to implement it in the freezing
cold Command Module with only Torchlight
to see by oh and just in case that
wasn't miserable enough any mistake
meant certain death
to the immense relief of everyone
concerned swing it swaggered his way
through the makeshift process and the
wounded Command Module slowly flickered
back into life with that out of the way
the service and lunar modules were just
Ascend off into space and Apollo 13 was
ready for re-entry
even then having come so far and gone
through so much nobody knew for sure if
they'd make it down to earth in one
piece the key concern was the heat
shield it had been perilously close to
the site of the oxygen tank explosion
and there was no way of knowing if it
had been damaged in the blast if the
heat shield failed the astronauts would
die a fiery death that was surely on
their minds as they shut themselves in
and prepared for the lights to go up on
the Final Act of the most extraordinary
Space Opera in history would they see
their families again or were they
seconds from an agonizing death
they were about to find out
[Music]
back on Earth Apollo 13 had gone from a
mission nobody cared about to the most
closely followed in history after the
Apollo 11 moon landing there had been
round-the-clock news coverage of the
astronauts plight and an estimated 70
million people were watching events
unfold on TV
many millions more had their eyes
trained on the sky
just to ratchet up the tension that
little bit further there would be a four
minute radio blackouts during re-entry
as the immense heat interrupted comes
the world held its breath as the seconds
take down and when those four minutes
were finally up Houston tentatively
radioed The Command Module
and got no response whatsoever
a full minute and a half past and still
there was nothing but just when it
seemed certain the Apollo Astronauts
perished at the very last hurdle Jack
swiggett's voice crackled into life on
the radio
Apollo 13 had made it The Command Module
splashed down in the South Pacific soon
afterwards not far from American Samoa
where the crew were picked up by the USS
Iowa Jima they were cold they were
dehydrated they were tired and they were
very very very glad to be home
Jim Lovell Jack swiggett and Fred Hayes
may not have walked on the surface of
the Moon but to this day they hold a
record for reaching the greatest
distance from Earth in history to put
that another way no human beings before
or since have ventured further away from
our home planet than the Apollo 13
astronauts even more importantly those
three men played the starring roles in
one of Mankind's greatest triumphs of
cooperation and survival
thanks for watching